nice is with us in Tulsa Oklahoma hi
Denise how are you hi Dave I'm good are
you better than I deserve what's up okay
so I'm one of those Millennials you were
talking about earlier today okay I'm 26
hmm I recently almost doubled my income
in the last seven months I now make
$80,000 why did it go yeah what do you
do I'm an engineering manager good for
you yeah I just got promotion so um what
I'm trying to decide now is I'm still
living on the income of made before so I
have about 2000 take-home different make
that I'm saving and putting toward my
debt about about $70,000 that I've seen
loans and a car I'm debating whether
silica or not I really like it so I
don't want to sell it okay um but I'm
trying to set if I want to buy a house
or continue the rent rent if yes you
need to keep running while you're in
debt I understand that it's just it's so
much more to rent
there is no buy nice buy only if you're
renting the wrong thing it would be the
wrong thing something that expensive to
where it's more to rent than it is to
buy but if you put two if you put two
properties just exactly alike side by
side it is not cheaper to to rent
because the landlord has to make a
profit yeah I guess I'm looking at
apartments and I currently have a
one-bedroom and I move far away so I
want to have stuff for family and
friends becomes isn't looking at
2-bedroom all right family and friends
to come visit when you're broken in debt
can stay in hotel
I agree but they don't see it that way I
don't care your jaw if they want to pay
your bills I get to have a vote but
until they pay your bills they don't get
a vote
yeah I just I don't know I just
and we nice to have something to look at
that I own other than a car something
that I've been started investing it
already yeah it would be nice for you to
not be broke before you start buying a
house I I guess I am still being a grip
on your uh your process well here's the
thing is not just my process that the
last two generations are the only
generations in the history of America
probably in the history of the world
that bought homes while they were deeply
in debt everyone else spent the first
few years of their life after school
cleaning up whatever mess they have
laying a solid foundation and they buy a
home a little bit later called wisdom
because when you buy a home in you're
broke Murphy will move in your spare
bedroom and bring his three cousins
broke desperate and stupid with him
everything that can go wrong in your
life will and you're going to delay your
not only your ability to get out of that
but your ability to build wealth and
build financial stability by buying a
home prematurely because a home is not
cheaper when the hot water heater goes
out it's a $500 bill from the plumber
when the heating air goes out it's a six
thousand dollar bill when the roof leaks
it's an eight thousand dollar bill when
the taxes come due and go up and the
insurance come to comes due and goes up
it's not less expensive to own on a
short-term basis owning on a long-term
basis is a great investment and it is
good to have something to own but you
cannot make financial decisions based on
your emotions or you'll be broke your
whole life that's what children do hello
I think she left okay well there we go
anyway that's how it works don't buy a
house when you're broke get yourself out
of debt get yourself a good solid
emergency fund get yourself a down
payment and then and only then should
you buy a house you're going to set
yourself back when broke people buy
houses it makes them broker and broker
and broker